[Music]  [Music]  the iconic franchise around the blue  hedgehog can't be kept down  paramount pictures announced his second  part shortly after the release of sonic  the hedgehog the popular character tails  already appeared in mid-credit scene the  orange yellow fox and good friend of  sonic was all along in search of his  blue buddy who was hiding from his  enemies first introduced in the video  game in 1994 the short beat hedgehog who  has also become famous for the ugandan  knuckles mean already became a fan  favorite back then due to his cool  demeanor the skilled climber could  therefore also play a role in the sequel  alongside tales  there's already a favorite for the voice  over in the film community namely none  other than dwayne johnson besides  johnson  names like samuel jackson and chris rock  are also circulating as dubbing actors  for the animated characters  however nothing has been officially  confirmed yet a release can be expected  on april 8  2022  you